I smile all day long from the moment I
wake up until I go to sleep so I'm not
dr. doom and dr. realist things were
worse I was talking about the downside
risk right now recognize there are lots
of outside there is a global economic
recovery is gonna be stronger in the US
than in Europe or Japan even emerging
markets are improving there is a little
bit more of confidence about this
recovery so animal spirits are sort of
back I'm released in the sense there are
lots of tail risks the problems of the
eurozone have not been resolved the u.s.
there is political gridlock that
prevents important reforms like
immigration and others I'm worried about
the hard landing of China was the
geopolitical risk in a global economy
from the Middle East is very Ron
so the lots of things can still go wrong
I wouldn't put it in bitcoins to me
bitcoin is a father's gonna implode like
a Ponzi scheme
I love contemporary art so at the margin
I like stuff that is nice to have an
investment you want to look at it in
your kind of home rather than having
stocks that are sitting into a drawer so
I would go for Contemporary Art